Hey, David, why do most white people vote
for Republicans?
This is this is a complex question that requires
a lot of different exploration.
And the answer is not because white people
are more.
Racist and they vote for Republicans that
that's not if that's what you believe, it's
overly simplistic.
There are, of course, elements of racism,
but that's really not what this is about.
So it is true that when you look at current
polling and you slice and dice it demographically
by age, by race, by income, you know, all
these different things, by education.
Donald Trump is winning among men by not not
by a huge margin.
Donald Trump is winning among white voters.
And Donald Trump is winning among uneducated
voters.
The more education you have, the more likely
you are to support Joe Biden.
The answer to a lot of the white support for
Republicans actually is religion.
And I want people to be very, very carefully
understanding what it is that I'm saying here.
White evangelicals overwhelmingly vote for
Republicans.
White non evangelicals are pretty split between
the Democratic and the Republican Party.
So to say it another way.
Were it not for white evangelicals?
The Republican Party would not have the advantage
it has among white voters.
And this is why you might see American politics
and you say there's more support for abortion
today than there has been at any time since
Roe v. Wade.
And yet, they say the Republicans still kowtow
to being against abortion and they still try
to play.
You know, they trump speaking at the March
for Life and all of this different stuff.
The reason why is that they are dependent
on the white evangelical voter, not only for
votes, but also for donations.
Evangelicals are just over a third of white
voters.
OK, so you've got all white voters.
A third of white voters are evangelical.
They voted for Trump.
Roughly four to one, 80 to 20 other white
voters went for Hillary, 56 to 44, according
to exit polls against Trump in 2016.
So when you slice and dice the electorate,
you start to understand that the analysis
that white people prefer Republicans, it's
not really getting at the core of the issue,
which in this particular case is religiosity.
Now, anytime you look at these distinctions,
you have to be able to separate causation
vs. correlation.
OK, I don't know exactly how that affects
the white voter element of it.
But for example, with education, you see that
people without a college degree are the most
likely educationally to be voting for Trump.
People with a college degree support Joe Biden
by by a pretty big margin.
People with a post graduate degree support
Joe Biden by an even higher margin.
The more education you have, the more likely
you are to support Biden over Trump.
I actually believe that is causal.
I think that education as a process makes
you less likely to be bamboozled by stupid
talking points from Trump.
Like I know all about trade and I will fix
it.
The more educated you are, the more likely
you are to realize Trump knows nothing about
trade and he's not going to fix it and you
shouldn't fall for it.
So that is causal to me with some of these
other things religion, race, whatever.
I think that we have to explore whether the
correlations have a causal component.
That's sort of not really what we were taking
head on, but that's the situation.
Yes, white voters support Republicans, but
were it not for white evangelicals, that support
would be very much in question.